people living inside the spanish trails
country club are outraged over animal
cruelty they say the geese that roam the
neighborhood are being killed today they
held a rally outside their neighborhood
at the corner of rainbow and tropicana
we spoke with someone who's lived there
for eight years and she says she wants
those responsible to be held accountable
spanish trail country club illegally
massacred hundreds of canadian geese the
population went from hundreds down to
five or four
these legals are
these
killings are illegal
and we're here today to make sure this
never happens again
community management told us the removal
of the geese is part of the controlling
of the animal population we reached out
to nevada department of wildlife who
provided a statement that reads in part
the spanish trails country club did
indeed have a permit to remove geese and
they are currently investigating whether
or not those requirements of the permit
were followed for now that permit has
been suspended